good morning John we are fast
approaching the 98th birthday of one of
my favorite people in the world though
he may be dead Alan Turing now Alan is
one of my favorite people in the world
because one he was a colossal nerd and
two he helped win World War two and
three he helped create the machine that
you are staring at right now and John I
love the machine you are staring at
right now I love it a lot and not only
was he making them but he was
programming to make codes for the
English military and to break the codes
of the German military yes Alan Turing
is responsible for many of the amazing
things that we enjoy today things that
may or may not include not living a
world governed by radical totalitarian
anti-semitic jerks and also may include
not living in a world where I am a
professional vlogger I don't even know
which one of those things would be worse
but one Island Turing did a lot of
amazing things for the world and
particularly for the British government
the British government did not do a
great job paying him back for that in
the 1950s Alan Turing was convicted of
being a homosexual which does not to us
sound like a thing that you can be
convicted of but yes he went to court
and there was a jury and they convicted
him of being a homosexual indeed it was
illegal in England in the 1950s to be
gay and Oscar Wilde was actually
convicted with the exact same law Oscar
Wilde was sentenced to two years hard
labour for being a homosexual Alan
Turing got to choose between his
punishments either two years in jail or
to undergo hormonal treatment to
decrease his libido Alan Turing chose
the second choice and took the estrogen
hormonal injections after his conviction
his security clearance was revoked he
was not allowed to work on any of the
computer that he had developed his name
was tarnished and there were
implications that homosexuals were often
spies
soon after in 1954 Alan Turing injected
an apple with cyanide and then he ate it
Alan Turing did everything that a person
can do to win the support of his nation
everything he saved thousands possibly
hundreds of thousands of the lives of
British soldiers he created machines
that would go on to revolutionize the
entire world but because there was one
thing that was a little bit different
about him
his entire country turned their back on
him I'm telling you this story because I
want to think about change this week The
Trevor Project is working on a video
contest called
be the change and sometimes it's hard to
see change it's hard to see change
happening especially for young people
like I
be like if you're 15 years old you can't
see how fast the world has changed
because really since you started paying
attention when you were 10 maybe the
world hasn't changed that much so it
might seem like nothing can ever change
and that's when people get desperate and
they do things like complete suicide
because they happen to be lesbians are
gay or bisexual or transgendered or
questioning but if you think about Alan
Turing then you can realize that so much
has changed and yes there is a lot of
change still to make but that doesn't
happen all at once there's never a
moment where everyone just agrees to be
tolerant it happens slowly it happens
very slowly and it happens through a lot
of different mechanisms but the most
important one is to change yourself if
enough of us change then the change
happens and that's what's happened that
is why you can no longer go to jail for
being a homosexual because people
changed individual people and how can
you be the change well you can support
The Trevor Project you can go to meme
labs calm slash Trevor Project and watch
a bunch of these videos and vote on your
favorites or you can make your own be
the change video and I hope that you do
John I will see you on Wednesday
you